welcome to my new little series on the
five most amazing pins or concepts of
pins in the chess world and of course
these my preferable and personal
favorites so you may differ but they
think you're fine they're all amazing
examples but remember to like and
subscribe to this video and we move in
to these pins in a jiffy this first
example is a nice simple demonstration
of a pin and it came from the World
Championship match between a decline in
1927 with the white pieces and
Casablanca
two brilliant players a decline with
white pieces a pin is where you tie down
you pin one of your opponent's pieces to
a more valuable piece so the rook to the
Queen here and f4 was now played and
here white removed one of the defenders
of the pin piece the knight defending
the rook and in this position trying to
work out how Anna Klein took best
advantage of this pin which black cannot
get out of and shortly cap blank was
forced to resign remember to pause for
out this video today and try to work out
some of the solutions for yourself use
that gray matter boys and girls well
here king - f2 was plate
maybe the rook could have come to that
square as well but I hope you did not
want to play rook to c1 here because
rook takes c1 is check and this is a
totally different ballgame but after
King f2 a very clever move maybe some of
you found that rook c1 is a major
threats and the game finished Queen f6
we don't want to allow a check so G 3G 5
and now rook c1 is a simple way to win
so crisp play from other kind air you're
gonna get a little bit tougher let's
move on to number 2 now
well sticking with the theme of Alekhine
in this case he was on the receiving end
with the black pieces in another world
championship match 1935 and this was
maybe one of the biggest upsets in a
World Championship match he lost to
measure
of the Netherlands and this game where
the black pieces was a key game it's
matched to play and to gain a winning
position with a very crafty idea quite
subtle this one and I do advise you if
you want to find the right move here you
have to really get into the mind of your
opponents and think what black is trying
to achieve in this position can you find
match yours move well if we play a
normal move black is gonna go Bishop b5
and this is something I think you know
lower rates players really need to do
more get into your opponent's mind so
for example let's say King F 1 Bishop to
b5 and black gets out of the pin if we
take the rook the bishop takes if we
take the bishop we're actually losing
after rook takes a 1 check so how can we
stop this only only one way that black
can play to get out of the pin well we
played the incredibly clever move up to
a 2 if you found this move you really
are thinking in the right way and now
black is an internal pin he can't ever
get his bishop or rook off the side of
the board Bishop b5 does now no longer
work because the pawn takes b5 and our
rook on a2 is safely defended and black
is in trouble here losing lost so after
this move rook a to white simply moved
his pawns up the board and got a winning
position we won't look at the rest of
the game just surface to say that black
is playing two pieces down from here on
in this third example is taken from a
game of David Bronstein often classified
as the chess magician with the black
pieces Hastings 1975 and with a little
mini combination here he creates an
unstoppable pin something I call an
eternal pin like we saw in the last
example where white is completely
helpless and this I feel has a lot of
beauty to it this one can you see in the
little sequence that Bronstein put into
motion here well he started with Queen
takes c3 and rook takes c2 which I'm
sure
you saw but after this is defended on d2
with rook d5 we come to the main point
of this you might want to pause again
here what is the winning idea we can
already see that the bishop is tied down
the least important piece the knight to
the more powerful piece so this is a
really strong pin but there's a lovely
idea here which stops white from ever
getting out of this pin route takes d2
giving up the exchange rook d8
increasing the pressure on the pin rook
d1 is now forced and if you saw the next
move you're obviously a very strong
player c4 and this is the real point of
this combination again quite subtle
that's why I pick these ideas why c4 you
might be thinking well the idea is to
stop white from ever breaking this pin
so again we got to think in the eyes of
our opponent what would our poni be
trying to do here well he wants to go c4
c3 king c2 and if he can push those up
onefile he breaks the pin and after c4
there's no no moves
eventually the white will be at a plate
black can just keep moving the bishop
backwards and forwards on this diagonal
and white will run out of mousse let's
just try that for example it's very
funny you know we just keep doing it it
doesn't matter
at some point okay we won't even take
the pawn white will run out a moose and
he has to drop the defense of d2 and
black will go piece up beautiful stuff
well it's black to play and win through
a very nice combination here and this is
from a game with not so well known
players even on that and niccola's
grieve Eliquis and in this position rook
b1 has been played pause now to try and
find the way to win this for black what
a way to win this is not what was played
in the game rook takes b1 which
eventually led to a draw but the idea of
Bishop a6 combining various pinning
motifs to win and this is a great
idea if the bishop is taken we win the
rook and we'll exchange up so white has
to really take our rook and now the
point behind us we go Bishop takes D
free check the King has to go to e1 and
now the killer pin Bishop to a5 and
after a move like king d2 Bishop to f1
bishops are fantastically strong pinning
Knights are fantastically strong at
forking and this kind of thing would be
completely winning for black so very
nice combination of pins there and a
nice sweet tactical sequence this last
example was one of the most fantastic
escapes that I've ever seen well I say
escape I know that the player the white
pieces my good friend Grandmaster Keith
Lockhart had planned this way in advance
he was playing very talented junior now
Grandmaster I believe James Holland or
at least an international master and it
looks like white is in all sorts of
trouble
there's pins all over the place
for example if white takes the Queen
boom
rook takes II one check mate we don't
want to allow that if we don't do
anything here let's say we go Queen
takes I don't know see six black can go
Queenie free and then Queen f -
checkmate
what else can white plate well it's very
very tricky because if something like
Queen f4 you can lose your rook and
that's the end of the game there's also
even a fret of Queen takes f3 in this
position so what move does white play
now to gain a better position and it's
an astonishing idea can you see it
tricky one pause now and you'll need to
pause I think well Queen to d8 you what
governor this move is really a great way
to pin the rook down to the king and
also it combines another technique of
distraction you're trying to distract
one of blacks pieces the rook or the
bishop away from its aggressive position
allowing us to win
Queen and this gives Whitely advantage
for example what can black play well the
bishop and rook are on pre if we go rook
takes d8 and this occurred in the game
white can now take the Queen because
there's nothing happening on e1 and
after some exchanges or need one just
rookie two and white went on to win this
ending where he where he has a favorable
position because the King is quicker to
come in if the upper option Bishop takes
d8 again we just take the Queen because
there's no threats only one so Queen d8
and an astonishing move there that gave
Keith the upper hand and I really hope
you like these examples and there's some
of the best examples and historical
examples of pins I could find remember
to Like and subscribe to this video and
the five most amazing or historically
important pins that have occured in
chess games over the history these are
obviously a bit subjective maybe you
think there's some better pins out there
but you can link to but I certainly
enjoyed the examples here which I found
through a bit of research thank you very
much and I'll hopefully be back with
more videos soon